former president donald trump has plans
to launch a new social media network and
before it has any working product
investors are suggesting it's worth more
than 10 billion dollars
trump plans to take this new entity
public through a special purpose
acquisition company shares for that
spack are already trading around 60
dollars a share as of december 2nd but
what makes a company that hasn't done
much yet worth so much money
so following the january riot on the u.s
capitol
uh donald trump was banned from a lot of
technology platforms he was knocked off
of twitter which he had famously used so
much during his presidency
he was suspended from facebook
so trump basically said okay if you're
going to ban me from all this stuff i'm
going to start a company that rivals
your technology platforms and i'm going
to open it up not just to people like me
but to all sorts of people and in doing
so i'm going to grab part of your market
share and make a tremendous amount of
money for myself while also giving
myself a megaphone and so that's a
really really interesting idea and one
that a lot of people are excited about
and that's why you see the value of this
company
right now surging so high
a spac is an existing company that is
publicly traded created for the purpose
of acquiring an existing company and
taking it public on a stock exchange the
spac exists as a pile of money until it
merges with a separate company giving
that company access to the spax money
so the pile of cash that you can buy
shares in
right now if somebody buys a portion of
that they're buying a portion of a pile
of cash that's 293 million dollars in it
but because people are so excited that
this pile of cash is going to merge
with trump's company they're valuing the
pile of cash way more than 293 million
dollars in fact that pile of cash the
shareholders who own it
once these companies merge if the share
price stays the same those shareholders
will be holding an interest worth two
billion dollars so you have people
valuing a 293 million dollar pile of
cash at about 2 billion because they're
excited that trump's going to get
involved
it's not clear how much of the trump
media and technology group donald trump
owns but there are indications he could
own a majority stake and at december 2nd
share price trump could hold a stake
worth at least 3 billion dollars if you
break it down donald trump when he was
president before he got booted from all
these technology platforms had amassed
about 150 million followers across
instagram facebook and twitter now 89
million of those were on twitter twitter
right now is worth about 30 billion
dollars and twitter has 211 million
people at last count that they can show
ads to on a daily basis so that means
that the markets are valuing twitter
at about 142 dollars for every person
that it can show ads to on a daily basis
so let's say that donald trump
convinces a third of those 89 million
former twitter followers that he had
to come with him onto his new platform
and to check it out every single day so
then they can send ads to it
and let's say that the market decides to
value trump's company like it would
value twitter
that would mean
that trump's company would be worth
about 4.2 billion dollars now you're
still a long way from the 8 billion
dollars that they're saying
that it's worth right now but if you
play with those numbers you could
convince yourself that it's not such a
crazy bet remember what they're talking
about doing here isn't just creating a
twitter knockoff it's creating a
competitor to twitter to disney plus to
netflix even to amazon web services so
if they can start to chip away at little
parts of those markets and you can
create you know a couple billion dollars
out of that you've got a few billion
dollars out of twitter
you could get to numbers where investors
might say hey wait a second the
opportunity here is way bigger than
eight billion dollars and i trust in
donald trump so much and i really really
want to buy and be a part of this thing
now that's an incredibly risky bet none
of this stuff exists yet they don't have
a product even for the first thing the
twitter knockoff let alone for other
things and convincing people to come
onto your platform isn't an easy thing
to do
nor is convincing advertisers to pay to
be on that platform but if you get
creative enough you could get to numbers
where you say okay maybe this actually
makes sense and then it's a question of
how much do you like donald trump and
how much risk are you willing to take on
[Music]